2e tour de france cycliste celui là avec
une étape beaucoup plus calme que celle
de la veille à fleurance et l'ancien
champion de france régis clair il l'a
emporté au sprint le français pascal
simon conserve le maillot jaune et
pourtant il est tombé dans des
conditions que certains ont jugées
douteuses
suffisamment en tout cas pour relancer
la polémique sur la loi du milieu dans
le peloton il a ce soir une omoplate
fracturée
d'autant qu'un peu plus tard on
apprenait que job douteux mais lequel
jean françois rodriguez s'était dopé
lors des premières étapes du tour
outre une amende il risque un
déclassement à la dernière place des
étapes incriminés et 10 minutes de
pénalisation au classement général alain
vernon un drame a marqué l'étape
d'aujourd'hui donc qu'on annoncé comme
une étape de transition après la
douloureuse traversée des pyrénées c'est
christian jourdan qui se relève ici mais
la chute du kilomètre 46 a surtout fait
une victime de marque puisque pascal
simon a bien failli monter dans
l'ambulance
pourtant la loi du tour dicte toujours
ces conditions et tandis que simon
repartez endolori régis clair le
champion de france 82 remporté au sprint
cette 11e étape à florence devant
jourdan bien revenu et laulan tfx pirard
le vainqueur de créteil c'est phil
anderson qui règle le sprint du peloton
avec deux minutes et 3 secondes de
retard tandis que hotmail qu'on
l'apprend convaincu de dopage rétrograde
à la 25e place avec plus de 16 minutes
de retard quant à simon il ne décolère
pas
après qu'un homme blessé je passe deux
fois de sa carrière un accident ou un
avantage vous entendu critiquer
violemment un bon adversaire un peu
d'eau oui parce que quand un labo jersey
il a il m'a dit c'est intel qui nous a
fait tomber maintenant c'est mon enquête
j'ai pas je pratique un coureur de
réussir s'ils n'en est pas responsable
mais s'il en est responsable et doit
être prise non c'est pas l'excision de
compte que c'est très bien qu'on se
lance dans le lot parce que lui sur voix
se bousculent et intense en ce moment là
on pourra faire plus attention que le
nom et je trouve pas ça fuse emballer ce
sont envoyés pour moi c'est librement à
preuve doit faire ses bourreaux qui est
tombé parce qu'il a touché la roue a
gardé puis moi j'étais dans les environs
c'est bon je ne savais même pas que
simon est tombé quand la chute s'est
produit mais c'est la guerre que tous
deux annoncés par qu'agostino partis eux
ils ont commencé à rouler moi je me suis
mis avec qui volait et puis un bourreau
a touché la roue a à son équipier puis
pourrait tomber et piment est tombé dans
sa roue vous plaidez vous coupable du
tout on va lister pascal simon souffre
ce soir d'une fracture de l'omoplate
gauche il devra conserver son bras
immobilisé durant près d'un mois
j'ai peur car je sentais un traitement
dans mon épaule et vers la remontée de
montréjeau j'étais sauvée loin mais chez
les souris les propos c'est bizarre j'ai
pensé besoin à la fin du tour de france
oui l'emporté sur la ligne paypal et je
dois dire un grand merci à toute
l'équipe de jour se font de manière
en avoir ramené à florence et maintenant
à moins d'avoir beaucoup de courage pour
essayer de finir c'est pour eux 30